- [Kelly] You actually
know Jada Slayy, I heard.
- I do. Where?
Ooh, my beautiful lady.
Oh, so inspiring.
- How do you know her? How do you?
- We worked together on 911.
- Oh, that's right. That's right.
(audience applauding)
- Yeah.
- Oh, I'm sorry.
(audience applauding)
- Oh, my gosh.
- So, so good to me.
- Have you?
- So good to me?
- Have you been able to
see a drag show in person?
- I've not.
So, I mean, I've seen pictures,
but to see it in the flesh is exciting.
I love it.
And we talked about, you know,
she would show me videos.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- But would you show me that.
- Of course.
- Jump, split, death prop?
- [Assistant] What is death
prop? (Angela laughing)
- I will.
- Wait, what's a jump split?
- I will for you, momma.
(audience applauding)
- [Angela] You give me a little of that?
- Okay, lemme show you.
- And you can do it in that outfit.
In those heels.
- Are you about to make
me feel bad about myself?
- Okay, here we go.
- What?
(Angela and audience applauding)
(Angela laughing)
- Owwwww.
Oh, my God.
- My thighs.
- I actually. Your thighs?
Oh, my God, I hurt.
Like just watching that.
- [Slayy] I'll show you.
- Oh, my God.
That was amazing.
- I did that in high school once
and that was the last time for me, so.
Thank you for that.
(Angela laughing)
- I have never done that
and I probably never will.
- I wanted her to do it on 911.
- I would literally have
to have so much alcohol
and a doctor for afterwards.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- Tylenol, please.
- [Kelly] That was amazing.
- Thank you.
- And a heating pad. That would hurt.